good morning John I am a little bit
shocked by how much I like jigsaw
puzzles like you might have noticed that
I'm a little bit obsessed with
productivity we can go ahead and say it
sometimes it's unhealthy I tie my
self-worth to my output and then I often
tie what I imagine to be my output to
external validation from an audience or
in economic terms or other imperfect
surrogates for the magnitude of impact
whatever that is a jigsaw puzzle has
none of that if there is something that
has less impact on the world than
reassembling an image of a wintertime
scene I Carolee think of it but jigsaw
puzzles trick my mind into thinking that
it matters without any of the
responsibilities of it actually
mattering and that allows me to get this
relax and also spend time with a friends
and family and there are lots of
different things I like about puzzles I
like how it feels like you get to know
every puzzle and they're all just a
little bit different and sometimes
they're very different and the tricks
you develop on one puzzle might not work
for another
and in these ways doing a puzzle is like
solving any problem no two problems are
the same but as you get the feel of the
shape of a problem you get better and
better at addressing it puzzles also
have the advantage of being finite and
so you know when you're done solving it
which is something that real world
problems tend to not have unfortunately
I am unlike a lot of puzzle people who I
know and that taking the puzzle apart is
actually my favorite part I just love
watching the complete order of a puzzle
being almost instantly reverted to
complete disorder and not because I like
love chaos and destruction like a little
bit I do but moat here's the thing I
love seeing how hard it is to build
something and how easy it is to destroy
it now that might not sound like a good
thought but I think it actually is
because if it is much easier to destroy
than build this is mathematically true
so you can't really deny it then
everything that remains built every
problem that gets solved every disease
that gets cured everything that just
works remains that way only because of
human action only because
billions of people placing puzzle pieces
every day carefully and thoughtfully
obviously during the project for awesome
we are focused on problems and the
puzzles were solving here are not
puzzles that have the luxury of not
mattering so we have to look a lot at
the problems and they can feel very
heavy but they need to be looked at and
they need to be understood and we need
to support the master puzzle solvers out
there who understand the unique shape of
each one of these things like the people
who work at Partners in Health and Save
the Children the charities the project
for awesome is supporting in its first
half the puzzle of healthcare isn't
simple anywhere but these organizations
help communities build more robust
healthcare decrease illness they provide
stability and they make the world a
better place everyone who supports the
project for awesome by making a video
supporting a charity joining us on the
live stream or getting some perks at
projectforawesome.com slash donate you
are helping put puzzle pieces down where
they most need to be the problems of the
world can feel like a weight but they
can also feel like a puzzle that yes
we're never gonna finish but that brings
a better world with every piece we lay
and the project for awesome by the way
begins shortly at noon Eastern Time and
you can join us for 48 hours of fun and
fundraising and silliness and
thoughtfulness at project for awesome
comm slash live John I will see you on
the livestream
when project for awesome calm slash
donate to find our IndieGoGo there are
so many cool perks and you can get them
now and only during the project for
awesome